in Britain and Ray Lugovoy is wanted for
murder in Moscow he sits in Russia's
Parliament and runs this restaurant with
his daughter nearly five years on he
maintains that he did not poison
Alexander Litvinenko he says Britain
should stop demanding his extradition
and the David Cameron himself longs to
drop the issue I am sure that this is
dream of camera don't speak about me
don't say about me it looks idiotic the
last four years the first question from
every British politician has been about
me despite the fact that Britain is the
biggest investor in the Russian economy
dissident former spy Alexander
Litvinenko died in a London hospital
after being poisoned with polonium 210
Lugovoy became Scotland Yard's chief
suspect on his deathbed Litvinenko
accused Vladimir Putin of ordering his
murder acclaimed the Kremlin denied
David Cameron is expected to be the
first British leader to meet Putin since
that allegation many believe Russia's
Matt show Prime Minister is priming
himself for another term as president
outnumber the demonstrators here this
kind of a lack of tolerance of any sort
of dissent is only likely to increase
pre-election months during an election
period getting too cozy with the West
won't be on the campaign to do list
there when the Russian leaders and
especially Putin is campaigning is
usually using enter west and sentiments
so there is no basis or prerequisites
for any warm feelings towards any
actually when put in this campaign
that's why I hardly do you know the
bright for putting state in this time
Alexander his wife Marina is aware that
issues like trade Libya and Syria will
likely dominate David Cameron's visit to
Moscow but she says she's confident the
British government won't let her down I
know life or one person you can't
compare with something very bigger but
is this one person it's just so big you
can't say how much it costs and you have
to be sure one day when you just get rid
of one life another day you lost enough
lives it will be bigger price but as the
world moves on any real hope of justice
for Alexander o will inevitably fade
Amanda Walker Sky News Moscow
you